el cirujano llevará a cabo la reparación
del aneurisma aórtico abdominal para
prevenir la ruptura de un área
protuberante de la aorta la arteria más
extensa del cuerpo es la aorta la que se
encuentra adjunta al corazón y recibe
sangre directamente del ventrículo
izquierdo o la cámara de bombeo
principal la aorta se encuentra dividida
en cuatro partes aorta ascendiente arco
aórtico aorta torácica y aorta abdominal
la aorta abdominal es la última y más
extensa sección de la aorta proporciona
sangre a las regiones inferiores del
cuerpo entre ellas los órganos del
abdomen y la pelvis la aorta abdominal
finaliza alrededor del nivel del ombligo
donde se divide en dos arterias ilíacas
que transportan sangre a las piernas la
aorta tiene una pared gruesa para poder
resistir la alta presión de la sangre
que es bombeada desde el corazón con el
transcurso del tiempo la pared de la
aorta se puede debilitar hinchándose
lentamente hacia afuera como un globo
cuando esa afección se produce en la
región abdominal se la llama aneurisma
aórtico abdominal
el cirujano llevará a cabo una
reparación abierta del aneurisma aórtico
abdominal cuando el diámetro de la aorta
exceda las 2 pulgadas 5 centímetros o si
se presentan síntomas como dolor
abdominal intenso o pulso
anormalmente prominente del abdomen
antes del procedimiento abierto por
medio de una vía intravenosa se le
comenzará a administrar líquidos
antibióticos y anestesia una reparación
quirúrgica abierta tradicional sera
con anestesia general lo que significa
que usted estará dormido durante el
procedimiento se insertará un tubo
respiratorio por la boca y en la tráquea
para ayudarlo a respirar durante la
operación cuando esté dormido se le
insertará un catéter en la vejiga para
drenar la orina y controlar el
funcionamiento de los riñones
el cirujano comenzará haciendo una
incisión desde el esternón hasta debajo
del ombligo
luego ubicará el aneurisma y bloqueara
la arteria aorta por arriba y por abajo
posteriormente el cirujano abrirá el
aneurisma
y ccoo será en su lugar un injerto
artificial con la misma forma y tamaño
de una aorta sana
el cirujano suturar a la pared del
aneurisma cerrado sobre el injerto
recientemente ubicado el injerto
reforzará las paredes de la aorta
el cirujano cerrará la incisión
abdominal con puntos la duración total
de este procedimiento por lo general es
de entre 4 y 6 horas
el cirujano llevará a cabo una
reparación endovascular del aneurisma un
procedimiento más nuevo y mínimamente
invasivo si usted padece una enfermedad
cardíaca grave o presenta un riesgo
quirúrgico mayor debido a la edad u
otras afecciones médicas antes del
procedimiento endovascular al igual que
con el procedimiento abierto una vía
intravenosa comenzará a administrarle
líquidos y antibióticos puede recibir
anestesia general o un sedante y una
epidural o anestesia regional para
adormecer solamente la parte inferior
del cuerpo
el cirujano comenzará haciendo una
pequeña incisión en la ingle por encima
de la arteria femoral luego insertar a
un cable guía en la arteria y lo
empujará cuidadosamente hacia el
aneurisma
se pasará un catéter o tubo hueco sobre
el cable guía que será empujado hacia el
aneurisma
utilizando imágenes de rayos x en vivo
como guía el cirujano pasará un injerto
de stent endovascular un tubo comprimido
de tejido metálico a través del catéter
hacia el aneurisma luego abrirá el
injerto el que será sostenido en el
lugar con ganchos metálicos y stents el
cirujano puede insertar le componentes
adicionales del injerto para extender el
injerto en los vasos que suministran
sangre a las piernas
una vez que el injerto haya sido ubicado
la sangre fluirá por el mismo no
alrededor del saco del aneurisma lo que
quitará la presión del aneurisma
por último el cirujano quitará los
catéteres y cerrará las incisiones de la
ingle el procedimiento por lo general
llevará de entre dos y tres horas luego
del procedimiento si tuviera un tubo
respiratorio el mismo se quitará y usted
será llevado a la unidad de cuidado
intensivo para la recuperación recibirá
líquidos y alimentos vía intravenosa
es posible que también tenga un tubo
insertado en la nariz o en el estómago
para remover secreciones hasta que su
intestino recupere su funcionamiento
normal la estadía usual en el hospital
para un procedimiento abierto es de
entre 5 y 10 días mientras que para un
procedimiento endovascular por lo
general es más breve de entre 2 y 3 días